[Musique]
la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents rien ne
va plus chez les ebooks label din imoca
fuyant le pallec son père arrive en
pleine forêt où elle rencontre merlin le
chanteur a marre chanteur qu'elle sur
lui-même un chanteur je lui faire un
bisou
bonjour la mère du chanteur on oublie
que pour chaque il va transformer suite
à la grève d'une certaine catégorie de
personnel notamment grève des services
de décoration des scénaristes des
costumiers et d'une grève tournante des
musiciens nous n'avons pas été en mesure
de vous présenter la dynastie des ebooks
dans des conditions idéales
nous espérons vous donner satisfaction
la semaine prochaine oui mais manque
d'accès jolly boys je recherche le
principe que va-t-il se passer
que va-t-il se passer pendant ce temps
dont la forêt le prince lui et nadine
sont véritablement désappointé résumé
ahmadi je cherchais partout où l'on va
pas rester comme ça ne manque pas pas
rester comme ça exactement toi au moins
et moi en toi
qu'allons-nous faire l'élu allons voir
les aubois
[Rires]
[Musique]